(man) the sharks are back,
and they're looking
for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that really
matters--What is it? Money.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
I'm seeking
a $3 million investment.
Whoa.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Are you gonna send money
to die here, Barbara?
Would you mind
your own business? You're out.
I'm trying to save
the money.
Mind your own business.
I don't care
what happens to you.
I'm trying to focus here.
I'm worried about
your money.
I'm trying to listen here.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
This is
a fractionally tiny market.
This is not a tiny market.
Tell me why I'm wrong.
Well--
All I know is
you're not selling anything.
It's sink or swim.
You've gotta get off your ass
and get out there and sell.
It's not our money that's gonna
change it. It's your effort.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-Made,
filthy rich investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-Filled city
of manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
First into the tank is
Jim Pittman,
with an easy way to take
a comfortable bed with you
everywhere you go.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jim Pittman.
I'm from
yorba Linda, california,
and my product is airbedz,
the original
truck Bed air mattress.
I'm here today seeking
$250,000
for a 15% equity stake
in my company.
Airbedz is
a custom-Designed air mattress
Specifically made to fit
in the bed of pickup trucks.
Our greatest features
are the cutouts
in the mattress sides,
which allows the mattress
to go around
and, more importantly,
over top of the wheel wells,
creating a sleep area
that utilizes
the entire back
of the truck.
With our rugged, heavy-Duty
cloth construction,
and our built-In pump
with both inflate
and deflate options,
airbedz now creates
a mattress that's--
a good night's sleep is
just an inflate away.
I believe in this product.
I know this product will be
a big success.
Why?
The camping industry is
a $56-Billion-a-year industry.
Is there that big a need
for people to sleep
in their pickup trucks?
There's, uh, there's a major
need. I mean, just try a--
So, Jim, let's say 1 in 10 guys
with a pickup truck want
an air mattress in the back.
How do I find them?
Where do I sell
this air mattress?
How do I get to my customer?
What does it cost me
to get to that customer?
The--currently, we're, uh,
we're already in all--
Pretty much all
the major warehouse stores,
on their dot-Coms.
We're, you know,
go to any of your
automotive accessory stores.
Go to
the sporting goods side.
Now you--'cause you're going
hunting, fishing,
to the river,
to the desert--
Does one size fit all,
or do I have to have
a different mattress...
No.
For every design of pickup?
No. We, uh--
with some
of our engineered features,
one size fits
your full-Size 8-Foot beds.
One size fits
your full-Size 6-Foot beds.
Jim, one important detail--
How easy is it
to pump this thing up?
Can I do it,
as a woman, all by myself?
Absolutely.
Do you need a gang
of people?
If I could show you?
Yeah.
Simple as turning
on the button.
(whirring)
Oh, you have a pump.
And battery-Operated.
The pump not only--
The pump not only inflates
your mattress...
(clicks, whirring continues)
You turn the Dial
to deflate it.
(Click, whirring stops)
now where's
the power source for that?
The pump operates off
a rechargeable
12-Volt battery.
There we go. Okay.
It's included in your packet,
and you have your home charger,
so you just plug and go.
Oh, that's cool.
It plugs
into your cigarette lighter,
so we always say, "bag to bed
"in 2 1/2 to 3 1/2 minutes,
"depending upon the application
of your truck--
Do you have an 8-Foot bed
or the 6-Foot bed?"
what are your sales?
Sales last year
were $210,000.
This year we're already
at $220,000.
What's your cost
of goods sold?
To--to make one mattress,
$50 to $60,
and we sell it
for $199 to $209.
That's retail,
though, right?
That's m.S.R.P.
And so when you sell it
to the camping stores,
what do you sell it--
Anywhere from $125
to, at some of
the bigger box stores, $145.
And, again, how many did
you say you sold so far?
This--This year,
about 1,700.
And the year before?
About 1,600.
You've come here to borrow money
to expand your business
and to build
inventory, right?
Well, n--We already have
about $400,000 in inventory
sitting in the warehouse
as we speak.
So you don't need inventory.
What do you need
my $250,000 for?
Uh, we're gonna--
The additional money would be
to bring in additional staffing.
Jim, why do you have
so much inventory in stock?
Well, it would seem that way,
but--But, y-You know,
with the understanding that
I'm a one-Man band
at the office.
You know, I'm dealing
with the big box stores.
I'm dealing
with the marketing,
so it takes away
a ton of time...
No, but--But why so--
So we have--
Why so much inventory?
Did you have to buy
that quantity
to get the price point?
No.
No, that's what I chose
to buy.
I got a feeling this is
a small niche market.
No, th--I mean, uh--
Uh, per year--
Jim, what percentage of people
need a mattress
in the back of their truck?
Go to any desert, any beach,
any place where you, uh--
there's--
Jim, can I try it?
Absolutely. Please.
Help me with this, Jim.
Barbara, you want to get
in bed with me?
No, thank you. No. (laughs)
Is this sturdy?
It's a truck.
Jump on it.
(chuckles)
whoo!
Oh. (chuckles) Gee.
Whoa.
Yeah, while Robert's sleeping
on the job, as usual...
(laughs)
Can I ask you
some questions, jimbo?
(Jim) You bet.
Um, how much money
do you have in this?
I've got over $250,000
of my own money invested
into the project.
Wow.
(Barbara) wow.
Well, where'd that money
come from?
(speaks indistinctly)
I'm a general contractor
and a real estate developer,
so I buy small houses,
bulldozer 'em,
and build big houses
on the lot.
How many competitors
do you have?
There's one person making
an air mattress
for the back of the truck.
It is not supported
by our patent,
and it has--none of 'em are
with a built-in pump,
so if you have
an air mattress--
I've never seen one
with a built-In pump.
I'll give you that.
Yeah, so--
Could--
Look, you've got
$400,000 in inventory...
correct.
Right?
Why are you not
selling more?
I mean, you're--
if it's international...
well--
and you're online, anybody
can place an order, right?
They could.
Bingo, Mr. Cuban.
It's because this is
a fractionally tiny market.
That's exactly
what This is telling you.
Mm.
He's got the best product
in the world,
and yet he's Only doing $100,000
worth of profit a year on it.
There should be
$2, $3, $4 million.
S-So, jimbo...
it's--
in a--
How do you solve
that problem?
Easy. Uh, y--
Uh, we're--We're--
Spend a ton of money
marketing.
No, not at all. Not at all.
(speaks indistinctly)
Okay, Jim.
Let me ask you again.
Why--
Why are you only selling
$200,000 of the world's best
back-of-the-Truck air mattress?
And there's no comp--
What's the problem?
And no competition.
Yeah, and there's no comp--
Nobody makes it. Why? Why?
Well, with your expertise...
No.
Y-You're bringing
in a n--a new--a new--
I am not an air mattress guy,
and, believe me, the rest
of these bozos aren't either.
At the end of the day...
no, they're not, but you--
This is about a tiny market.
You've gotta refute it.
You've gotta tell me
why I'm wrong.
Oh, you're absolutely wrong.
This is not a tiny market.
Well, tell me why.
This--This is a market
that--That's been around
for 20 years.
It's gonna be around
for 20 more years.
You're, like, you know,
where were we at 20 years ago?
That's probably
my best compliment I could get.
See, I disagree with--
With the undertaker here.
I know.
You know,
he's the undertaker
'cause he's where
businesses go to die.
(laughs)
Boy, isn't that True?
This one's already dead.
It doesn't have to visit me.
No, it--
cause he's...
(laughs)
It's just starting to grow.
I-I don't disagree with you
that I see a market there,
because, look, if you're
the only player,
you don't have--It doesn't have
to be a huge market, right?
You can dominate a niche.
But the problem, Jim,
is that you haven't
been dominating.
You know, you've got the--
Well--
You've got what appears to be
a great product, you know,
but something's missing.
You're telling us
these numbers.
there's a market there,
even if the undertaker doesn't
fully understand it.
(chuckles)
The undertaker speaks
the truth.
That's the problem.
Tell me why I'm wrong, Jim.
But--No.
You're speaking the truth
of what you know.
You--There--
there's still additional--
All I know is
you're not selling anything.
Well, we're not selling
because we don't have
a sales force that's
going out there to sell.
That's the reason?
We--we have you,
the buyers, coming to us,
saying,
"we like the product."
Jim, you keep on Digging B--
Deeper holes, right?
Yeah.
If I had my life savings,
everything,
on the line in a business,
which I've had before,
where if I don't sell,
I don't eat--
And trust me, I lived off of
mustard and ketchup sandwiches,
and that's no lie, okay?
If that was me, if I saw
a truck in the driveway,
I'd be knocking
on the door, selling,
and I would be able to go
door-to-Door
and sell
more than 1,700 units.
Sales cures all.
You've gotta get off your ass
and get out there and sell.
It's not our money
that's gonna change it.
It's your effort...
(Kevin) It's you.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
You know, you're
the number one mattress.
Everybody agrees
the quality is the best,
and yet you can't sell it,
and I personally think
it's a tiny niche market,
'cause you're not able
to convince me otherwise.
I have zero interest in
investing with you, my friend.
I'm out.
Jim...
you're not selling.
You're putting it on shelves,
and you're not selling
directly to the consumer.
Uh, it could be
a great product,
but you haven't proved
that today.
I'm out.
(mouths words)
You know, I-I chose to take
this market slow.
I wanted to test out
my product.
I wanted to get
into the niche markets.
We just need to get it into--
to--to more of the masses.
It sounds like you're still
at the testing stage...
not at all. No.
And I can't afford for you
to test with my money,
so I'm out.
Jim, four sharks are out.
You got one shot left--Barbara.
I just love the product.
There's a lot of guys
with trucks out there,
but I have a couple
of detail questions
that are
enormously important.
One, do you have a patent
on the mattress
or the blowup device?
I have a--I have four patents
on the mattress.
(sighs)
What bothers me most about
your pitch today--
And This is why
I'm sitting on the fence--
You're not a salesman.
You can't sell.
What are you going to do
to convince me
to put my money in?
This is your one shot.
Everybody else is out.
I want to hear how
you're gonna convince me.
Well, we're gonna jump
right into--
Both feet--
the 3,500 existing contacts
we have
of--of all of the--
Kinda--It would be like
the, uh, grassroots effect.
So the list of 3,500 people
who said they were
sort of interested--
You're gonna suddenly now go
home and start calling them?
Well, we're bringing people
in to do that.
I'm doing it as well,
but b--Running
the day-to-day business,
it's kinda hard to go str--
Directly into, you know,
more than 10 or--Or 15
SALES Calls per day,
where if we're hitting
50 SALES Calls per day,
now you're--
You're increasing--
That's just such an--Uh, sorry,
but that's just such an excuse.
Sales is the lifeblood
of your business.
The only thing you should
be doing right now
is selling this stuff.
I mean, I-I'm out,
but I gotta tell ya,
I hate when people say
stuff like that.
Are you gonna send money
to die here, Barbara?
What are you doing?
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Barbara is Jim's last chance
to make a deal.
Are you gonna send money
to die here, Barbara?
What are you doing?
Would you mind
your own business?
You're out.
I'm trying to save
the money.
Mind your own business.
I don't care what happens
to you.
I'm trying to focus here.
I'm worried about
your money.
I'm trying to listen here.
The business is just
being born.
We're--
We're--We've exceeded
the entire last year's sales
already, as of today.
We'll be at $400,000
by the end of the--by december.
All right. I'm gonna make you
your full $250,000 offer...
but you better not lose
my money.
I'll guarantee it.
But I want to have 50%
of this business.
Wait. Before you start
nodding your head "No,"
picture this with me
for a minute.
Picture your beautiful truck
on qvc,
not only nationally,
but internationally.
There's no reason this has
to stay in the U.S.
I mean, the idea
that you're not selling--
honestly, 'cause the product
is so good--
10,000 of these a day is
mind-boggling to me,
but you've gotta move out
of the way as a salesman.
Let a professional sell it.
Put your big truck
in with your mattress.
Barbara, who's selling
who here?
I'm selling him...
(mark) Yeah.
Because I can see
you're not a businessman.
Wait. Jim. Jim, let me--
Let me recast her offer.
I--
Yeah.
I get it.
I get it, all right, man?
You really do get it?
I don't think
you fully get it.
(Robert) Well, if--
she's saying,
"I'm gonna come work
for you full-Time,"
because you can't sell
but she can,
and she's gonna pay you
$250,000 to do it.
That's a no-Brainer.
Mm.
But it's not.
It--the--the sales are
where they're at,
uh, you know?
But you don't have them.
It--It's--
are you declining
her offer?
I'll counter you
an offer back...
that's fair.
If you'll accept that.
What do you have?
Um, my counteroffer That
would be back would be 25%.
(daymond laughs)
That's what you get, Barb.
I'm gonna give you...
you know, it's--
a moment to rethink that.
Yeah. No.
My--My decision's final.
That's your final decision?
It's 25%.
Well, good luck. I'm out.
Thank you.
He's a fool. He's a fool.
I could sell hundreds
of thousands of these.
That guy made a huge mistake,
but I have a great feeling
of relief that you didn't
kill that money.
I appreciated the offer
from Barbara for $250,000,
but 50% of the company was
just something
I wasn't willing to give up.
♪♪♪
This season,
we watched Shelly ehler
make a deal with Lori Greiner
for her cover-Up towel
for kids, show no.
I like you so much,
I'm gonna write you
a check right now.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's see what
they're up to already.
♪♪♪
Hi there, and welcome
to magic kingdom.
(Lori) today I brought Shelly
to walt Disney world in Florida.
We made a deal with Disney to
sell our towels in their parks.
I have to tell you,
we absolutely love your product.
It was perfect
for our water parks,
so how about we go take
a look?
(indistinct screams
and laughter)
I cannot wait for you
to see this.
All right, Shelly.
Here we go.
Here is the product.
(high-Pitched voice) Oh.
What do you think?
(Shelly) to see that towel
with Mickey and Minnie on it
and to know that
I've really come that far
is just unbelievable.
Thank you so much.
That is so beautiful.
(laughs)
I love it.
Honestly, a few months ago,
I sat in my sewing room
and made every single towel
by myself... (chuckles)
And now in just
a few short months,
Lori's overseeing
the manufacturing,
we're selling it
to Disney parks,
and it is absolutely
unbelievable.
Honestly, I could just
start sobbing.
(voice breaks)
like, I'm not even kidding.
I am just so appreciative
to "Shark tank" and to Lori
for believing in me
and for taking me this far.
Mom!
Did you have fun?
Yeah!
All right! Ooh!
Today's a day
I will never forget,
and to have my husband
and my boys here with me
is more than I could
ever ask for.
♪♪♪
My name's Scotty Olson.
I'm from
the land of 10,000 lakes,
and I'm also the innovator
and founder
of skyride technology.
I'm here today seeking
a $3 million investment
for a 20% stake
in this exciting company.
Whoa.
Let's take a look
at the moving star in action.
As you can see,
skyride's much like
a thrilling ride
of a Roller coaster,
but more than that,
it's powered by you,
the skyriders.
We're gonna be launching
fitness, recreation,
transportation in the sky
and getting people
of all ages
and, more importantly,
of all abilities
flying and moving faster
than they can possibly ride
their bicycle.
This is exciting.
It's real.
You're one of the very first
to see it,
and we're looking
for the right partner
to come on board to help us
take it to the world.
Scotty, are you nuts?
(Robert chuckles)
Uh, I've been told that
many times over the years.
I've been, um, inventing
innovating products.
That's a passion of mine.
Have you invented anything
in the past that we would know?
My claim to fame is
the rollerblade inventor.
I started the company
25 years ago,
and a lot of people said
the same thing to me.
You know, "that's never
gonna happen,"
uh, and I proved 'em wrong.
Scotty, you invented
rollerblades?
I-I did. I did.
I'm the--I'm the--that's
my claim to fame,
and I made a ton of money.
How much money
did you actually make
on that rollerblade adventure?
Oh, enough money
to--to, uh...
can you give us a number
to just--
Oh, you're relentless
on that. Um...
okay, well, let's play the game.
Was it more than $5 million?
Oh, yeah. I made
more than $5 million.
Was it more than $20 million?
Oh, boy. It's been so long ago,
I can't remember it.
Oh, come on now!
(daymond laughing)
Come on. Come on, Scotty.
You can--
You know what?
You never forg--
Scotty...
it's like your first date.
Has anybody ever--
I had a--I had a shark
come in...
Yeah.
And, uh--
Funny he pointed to you.
Yeah.
A bad shark?
And took advantage of it,
because my business partner
embezzled all my money from me.
Scotty, did you actually bring
rollerblades to the market,
or did you just simply invent it
and then sell it to someone?
Yeah, it's, uh--Uh,
I brought it to the market,
and I want to make
another star,
and, um, my commitment
to this product, the skyride,
it's, uh,
it's a big picture,
because I've had this idea
going on for 20 years.
How did you come up
with the idea?
I came up with the idea
because, uh, I wanted to be able
to create a superfast machine
that you could train on,
so I thought, wow, it would
be really cool to be
on a track and not have
to really worry about
other bikes or cars
or, um, anything like that.
Tell us the vision.
Let's say, like,
sky clubs,
where people would come in,
and they would,
you know, pay
anywhere from $25
to maybe $100
to train
on the sky track...
No, but what--What--
or the sky machine.
What do you have today? Do you
have anything working or--
Oh, yeah. Uh--Uh,
as you saw in the video,
I invested... (chuckles) Uh,
a considerable amount of time...
How much?
And money.
I have, uh, close
to half a million dollars.
Let me ask you a question,
staying on the money theme
for a second,
keeping you focused there.
I can buy 20% of this
for $3 million cash from you.
That means you're telling me
the whole business,
the concept is worth
$15 million.
Easy.
Do you have any sales?
No, I don't have sales,
but we have...
good, 'cause that could've--
Letters of intent.
That could've confused it.
What's the vision for you
to monetize this?
This isn't something
I'm gonna buy for my house.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, you could.
I call it the yard gym,
because I have people
right now--
Like, uh, to answer
your question,
I don't have a sale yet...
right.
But we have, uh,
people that are interested.
How many acres of land
did it require?
I mean, it could be,
uh, 100 feet long,
and you could have
a really nice, tight track.
You'd be like a gerbil
on a wheel.
(laughs)
Well, you might need 200 feet,
but it isn't the distance
as much as the movement...
whoo! (chuckles)
(chuckles)
You know, because how long
can you stay...
I mean...
on a stationary bike?
Scotty, you're asking families
to take up their whole backyard
with infrastructure--
Posts, cement...
okay, but that's--
(Barbara) Scott.
That's a--that's just
a part of it.
Time out.
I so respect you
for this enormous dream
you have,
but I just don't think
it's going to happen,
so I might as well clear
the deck and say I'm out.
Okay, that's not a problem,
but--But thanks
for being honest...
okay.
And I like that,
but we had, uh--uh...
I wish I believed.
Many different markets come
to us--Uh, recreation,
and the big one
that we're going after now
is in the billion-Dollar
ski industry.
So the plan is to sell it
to ski resorts?
That's, well, that's the l--
That's the low-Hanging fruit
for us right now.
Scott, it looks incredible,
but I wouldn't even know
where to start,
so I'm out.
But you may want one
in your backyard.
I'm out.
Scotty, my sense of you--
and I-I want you to take this
in a positive light--
is you're the inventor/idea guy.
You're not an executional guy,
in terms of doing any
of this stuff.
I took rollerblades from nothing
and started that company.
If you came to ride it,
you might say,
"Hey, I want one
for my backyard."
You know what? I do like
the idea for my backyard.
Yeah.
(Robert) Yeah. It--
I think it would be
really, really cool...
Well, s--
But my problem, Scotty, is
that it's gonna take a lot
of construction management
expertise.
I agree.
That's not--That's not me.
I don't have any expertise
there at all,
and so for that reason,
I have to drop out.
(clicks tongue)
Scotty, I-I love things
that make you go fast,
but I don't see the large-Scale
consumer application for it.
No, uh, we--That--That's not
our main focus in the backyard.
It's certainly
the ski resorts.
Scotty, it's
an admirable goal,
but I can't fly with you
on this.
I'm out.
Okay, I'm the only guy left,
Scotty, and here's what I say.
I wish every investment I made
made money, But they don't.
Some fail.
You should think about
your ideas the same way.
This is a dog from hell.
This is a very bad idea.
It howls at the moon,
and you should take it out
behind the barn
and shoot it.
It's over with this one.
Get something else going.
This sucks.
No, I'm just starting.
I'm out.
Go get 'em, Scott.
Go get 'em.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
Appreciate it.
Nice to see ya.
Didn't want those guys anyhow.
We're looking for an Angel,
not a shark.
Personally, if this was
an amusement park...
It'd be cool.
I would pay...
You'd try it.
To ride it, to play it...
it looks very cool.
Because I would say--
You need a small--
Oh, my god.
You need a smaller model.
This was made
for mark cuban.
You gotta be 7 feet tall
to use this.
Next.
♪♪♪
Next into the shark tank
are Queenie Davis
and Andrew Goodrum,
with an innovative way
to accessorize shoes.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Queenie Davis...
and I'm Andrew Goodrum,
and we are here today
asking for $100,000
in exchange for 30% equity
in our company.
Today we want
to introduce you
to one
of our original products,
the innovative,
the hot, New boot illusion.
Now boot illusions are
the next step
in ladies footwear.
It's a product that allows you
to go from a boot to a shoe
or a shoe to a boot...
just like that.
Today, I'm wearing a pair
of low-Cut, trendy,
a little funky boots,
but now watch.
The magic begins to happen
when we unzip it.
I simply grip it
and slip it off my foot,
and I'm back in my shoes.
It's that simple.
Now initially when you purchase
a boot illusion,
you not only get
a wonderful boot,
but you get
a fantastic shoe as well.
One of the benefits
of this product
is you can purchase
additional uppers
without having to buy
another shoe.
In fact, you can
interchange this upper
with shoes that you own
and have in your closet already.
The boot illusions comes
in a variety
of styles, colors,
fabrics, and lengths.
You can literally fill
your closet
full of tons
of fantastic boots
at a fraction of the cost
of traditional boots
and less than a quarter
of the space.
This product is a Winner.
This is the original,
hot, New boot illusion.
Anything else is
just bootleg.
(laughs)
Boot-a-licious!
(mark and Queenie Laugh)
Can we look at it?
Sure, and I want you
to know,
these are, uh, boots that are
made at my kitchen table,
so the sewing is not great,
and I don't claim to be
a s--a seamstress,
but I-I just--
So you haven't sold
any boot illusions yet,
if this is prototypes, right?
Not boot illusions, uh, no.
Our company, uh--
in June,
we went to a trade show,
and we did sell about
$130,000 worth
of our other product.
Which other product?
What's the other product?
Uh--
um, our other products
are rain boots
as well as, um...
why don't you pull 'em out?
Interchangeable sandals.
So, Queenie, you're just
selling equity
in just
the boot illusions line?
Absolutely not.
It's the company.
So you make the whole thing...
Yes.
Just a standard boot
and sandal?
Yes.
And you're doing all this
out of your house?
Uh, no. Uh, a funny story.
Uh, we... (chuckles)
We came up with these products
at the end of last year.
I had a dream that I went
to turkey,
so I literally jumped
on a plane, went to turkey,
and found a manufacturer.
These are--
How did you get to turkey?
Well, I just heard "Turkey--
We're boarding" in my ear.
I was try--We was trying
to figure out
where we was gonna go.
Right.
I don't want
to sound flighty,
but, you know, I was really
concentrating on it.
You already sound flighty,
so don't worry about it.
(laughs)
Yeah, Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, don't worry
about that.
(laughs)
(Andrew) right.
That ship has sailed.
So--But I did.
I just literally booked
a flight and said,
"Andrew, we gotta go
to turkey."
He said, "no, you gotta go
Right.
"I gotta work." (chuckles)
So I did. I went to turkey.
Right.
(chuckles)
I didn't know anyone there.
Uh, amazing.
It was just by happenstance
that they were having
a large shoe show.
Are you two married?
No, we're not.
No, we're--
We're very good friends.
Can a woman walk
in those shoes inside a boot?
It seems clunky.
No, it's not clunky at all.
No, not the way it's designed.
Uh--
It's well-Designed,
actually.
Right.
But it's not gonna work...
it leaves
the important part.
Yes.
In the winter, is it,
Queenie?
It abs--
I mean, if you go
in New York city in the slush
with this, it's not gonna
protect the shoe.
Yes, it is. It's rubber.
It--It works--It works best
in the winter.
How much money have
you invested,
and is it all your money?
So far, we invested about
$40,000 of our own money.
And what's the split
in ownership
between the two of you?
50/50.
When you guys disagree,
how do you decide?
I mean, we haven't had
that problem.
That's because you're not
sleeping together.
No, we've dis--
(men laugh)
Yeah, well, we've disagreed
a lot.
(laughs)
We disagree a lot.
Right.
Yeah.
What's the price range?
About $25 is
the manufacturer cost.
The tall ones--About $32.
Now, listen, the average cost
of a tall, leather boot is $299.
We're gonna retail these boots
anywhere from $129 to $179.
What's the cost
on this one here?
The r--
the one you have
on your foot--
the cost of that
to make it...
This is $25, right?
And what do you
sell it for?
Yes. Yes.
(Andrew) right. $25.
$25.
To make it?
$25 to make it.
And to sell it for?
Uh, $79.99.
To the store?
No, to our end customer.
Your end customer
being who?
Your--
Yeah. Our, uh--
the--the--
Our direct customers.
So online customers?
Online. Yes.
Oh, you're not selling
to retail outlets?
Oh, you don't--
Well, you know, that's what
we've been doing
at the trade shows.
You know, stores, boutiques
come in and purchase it.
But you don't have
a large retail presence?
You don't have somebody--
No. No.
No, right now we're trying
to get a voice
for the, um, boot illusions.
Barbara, what do you think
about these?
I think it's ingenious,
and you know why
it's a great product?
Shoes are so expensive.
I hate ruining a pair of shoes
and paying the Shoemaker again
to re-Sole my shoes.
It's terrible,
and if I could save the money
by Just slipping something
really cool-Looking
on top of my shoe...
I love this product.
So, Queenie,
I don't understand anything
about women's shoes
or fashions.
I think
it's a pretty good idea,
just nothing that
I'm gonna add any value to.
I'm out.
Guys, the bottom line is
I have no feel
for the retailing
of women's fashion,
so I can't help you
at all...
okay.
Okay.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Queenie, I love your shtick.
I love it, you know? You've got
an answer for everything...
(laughs)
Yes.
But here's something
that grinds me back to reality.
Yes.
You know, I look
at numbers...
Mm-hmm.
All right?
You're doing $120,000
in sales.
If you paid yourself
even a $40,000-a-year salary,
you make no money. Zero.
You're not profitable yet.
You're telling me
your business--
'cause you're gonna sell me
30% for $100,000--
Is worth close to $300,000--
More than $300,000.
It's not...
we understand it's not.
And--
If you know
it's not worth that,
why did you ask me
for that value?
Why did you do that?
Because--
How do I punish you
for that mistake?
Listen, these shoes, to women,
are like boys and Candy.
Once you see something
you like...
(chuckles)
You--It--It gets
in your head.
(Robert laughs)
You gotta have it,
and you--You don't stop
until you get it.
I have a voice in my head, too.
You know what it says?
Mm-hmm.
I'm out.
Oh.
That's good. Thank you.
Thank you for listening.
I do appreciate it.
So you went to turkey.
Mm-hmm.
(chuckles)
Did you just walk
the streets?
Did you know anybody there?
I'm--I'm--
(Andrew chuckles)
Absolutely not.
I didn't know anyone. Um--
And how did you get
to a manufacturer in turkey?
(Andrew) The--
Uh, the--the--
because... (chuckles)
the--
Because, uh,
there was a woman
who a friend of mine knew
who knew a doctor
who had--Knew someone
who had a family member
who worked in the shoe industry.
Wow.
(Andrew chuckles)
of course.
I'm a dreamer,
and I didn't think
of this product.
I had a dream
of the boot illusions.
Wait, Wait, wait, wait.
All of a sudden, in a dream,
building boot illusions
came to you?
Well, my cousin visited me,
and I was, like--
It, uh--
I was looking
at her boots...
it sounds wild, but...
and I was like...
(chuckles)
"Wow, those are so nice."
She--and then she laughed
and she said,
"those aren't really boots.
These are boot illusions."
And she unzipped it
and took it off.
I said, "I gotta see it,"
so I looked at it--
she had the product?
In the dream.
This is all in a dream.
Oh, this is a dream. Oh.
So the next morning...
(laughing)
I went out
and bought a machine.
You're telling
the movie backwards.
Yeah. (chuckles)
Yeah.
Really. Really.
So I have an offer.
I want to give you
the $100,000 for...
75%...
of just
the boot technology,
because I want
to license it.
Every dollar that comes in--
You will get 25 cents of it.
You just open
your mailbox...
hmm.
And see the money.
So are you willing to step
aside on this business
and just say, "sure, do with it
whatever you want, daymond"?
absolutely not.
All right.
Then listen to my deal.
So now you're gonna do a deal
with a real estate agent?
Let me listen.
Let's--Let me hear.
Let's hear her deal.
So I'm gonna give you
$100,000 for 55%...
Mm-hmm.
Not because I'm greedy...
But because I know
$100,000 ain't gonna
make it happen...
right.
Right?
And I'm also gonna take 55%
because I-I'm honestly
more experienced than you
at s--Building a business.
Absolutely.
Sure. Sure.
Every one of the entrepreneurs
I invested in have--
Are making a fortune, all right?
And I think my worth is--
Should certainly the--be
the majority interest.
And by the way,
she's gonna all of a sudden
be in
the manufacturing business
and learn that business,
too, with you.
Queenie, when you call
Barbara and say,
"I want to go to the Cobb show
Or nasby SHOW,"
whatever the c--May--
Case may be,
she won't have
the slightest idea
what you're talking about.
You know, that is so untrue.
(Kevin) Okay, wait a second.
Queenie, listen.
This is not her business.
Listen, I am
your sleep therapist,
and it's now time to make
a decision.
(sighs)
before you start dreaming again,
you're still here
in the real world.
What are you going to do?
You know what I want you to do
before you make a decision?
Please, Barbara.
Go out in the hall
and call any entrepreneur I've
gone into business with...
ohh.
Oh, god.
And see what they say.
Listen, and I believe
in you, so...
N--
We accept. Yes.
(Robert) WHOO!
(Kevin) Whoa.
(mark)
There you go, Barbara.
Way to go, Barbara!
And you know what?
You've got great judgment.
Yes. Yes. (chuckles)
Well, daymond, she showed you.
(mark) Daymond, hey.
She didn't show me crap.
No, she didn't.
No way.
You made a great decision.
I know I did. I know.
(chuckles) Thank you.
Are you crazy?
(Robert) Andrew,
I'm looking at you...
huh?
And I just want to know,
do I sense a little doubt
in your eye?
Uh... (sighs)
'cause you're 50/50 owners.
A guy with 20 years' experience
in the business?
"Let's go
with a real estate agent."
I don't--I don't regret it,
but I-I did favor
the godfather of urban fashion.
So we--and we appreciate
every one of you,
and, Barb, I just thank you.
Thank you for the offer.
I love you back.
I love you. (chuckles)
okay.
Sweet dreams.
Good luck, guys.
Bye. All right. (chuckles)
(chuckles)
75% of the company?
No. Mnh-Mnh.
She should have went with me.
My structure's in place.
Uh-huh.
I'm telling you now,
that was a big mistake.
Daymond, she dreamt
about going to turkey.
She dreamt the product up
in a dream.
Yeah.
Now she can dream about
the $5 million of sales
that could have been
done tomorrow.
That $5 million just flew
out the window.
My initial gut was, um,
really to go with daymond.
But 75% was way too much,
and so we're so happy
Barbara gave us a deal.
♪♪♪
(man) Let's go. Come on.
(whistles)
Next up is Fleetwood Hicks,
with a business inspired by
his best friend, Deville.
Oh! (chuckles)
(laughs) What a face.
My name is Fleetwood,
and this is my dog Deville.
He's also the brand icon
of my company, villy customs.
We looking for
a $500,000 investment
for a 33% stake
in our company.
Villy customs is the new way
to buy your bike.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give me a drumroll, please.
(drumroll)
I'd like to introduce to you
the world's first
fully customizable fashion bike.
Anyone from ages 8 to 80
can go to our web site
and select the colors
and the styles
and create their bike
the way they want it to be--
wild and crazy
or sophisticated and smooth.
I've taken
my background experience
in the fashion industry
and crossed over
into a whole new market.
As you can see
from the screen,
using our Web site, you can
select all your part colors
and see what your bike is gonna
look like before you buy it.
With all the features
that we offer,
you can build
over 1 billion bikes,
and not one
would be the same.
Villy customs
is about to explode.
We have the product,
we have the passion,
and we have the know-How to
become a major lifestyle brand.
I know you can't resist Deville
or these amazing bikes.
So who'd like to gear up and get
rolling with villy customs?
(pants and groans)
(sharks laugh)
I'm in.
(Robert) All right,
I'll scratch his tummy.
But do you have the sales?
Uh, currently, uh, we're
projecting $250,000 in Sales.
Uh, he's having a good time.
(mark) He is.
Uh, $250,000 in sales
for 2011.
Uh, we've only started
our Web site 12 months ago,
and we've already
increased sales by 100%.
What were your--So your sales
last year were $125,000?
$129,000,
and that was out of
a brick-And-Mortar retail store.
Um, we were just selling sort
of, like, regular bikes, though.
And, Fleetwood,
are the sales today are online?
100%.
And let me add, too--
No advertising.
We have not spent a dollar
on any type of advertising.
And would the total cost
of the bike be
once I customize?
The sales prices right now
on our bikes
are averaging $641
for a fully customized bike.
That is not cheap.
(mark) That's a lot of bike.
That's not great--That's
not--That's not expensive.
It's a very high end,
high end price point for bikes.
Kevin, have you ever seen
a-a cruiser bike like this?
No, no.
I-I-I get it, but--
But the idea is that this is
a fashion statement
towards a higher end
demographic.
A designer bike.
Yeah.
This is a style accessory.
And I will just say this,
you guys.
The customers
that have bought our bikes,
they don't even question
the price.
If we sell ten bikes a day,
we'll be doing
$2.1 million in sales.
That's a lot of bikes, though,
Fleetwood.
It's not very many bikes
at all.
How many are you doing now?
This is a $600 million market.
Well, no, this is--No...
How many--How many bikes have
you sold per day the past week?
This year, we're gonna sell
350 bikes.
One a day.
Fleetwood, you didn't say
how much it cost you
to make that bike.
What does it cost you?
Including shipping, $245.
All right, $250,000
in sales this year.
How much you gonna make
off that?
We're gonna make
about $50,000.
After you've
paid yourself something?
I haven't paid myself anything.
But like I said--
So if we normalized your salary,
we would break even, right?
(Robert) No.
Don't you think
you're worth $50,000?
We're a little over--I'm worth
a whole lot more than that.
(mark and daymond Laugh)
Yeah, but I'm trying
to figure out--
This is why I've been
doing this. This is my baby,
and I'm--I've put in blood,
sweat, and tears on this.
All I gotta do
is get out there.
Example--NBA, sports teams,
schools, colleges,
organizations.
But somebody has to do that.
Then you gotta build them
and you gotta get the orders.
Let me
point another problem out.
Maybe, uh, the dog can answer
this question.
He doesn't look like he's gonna
be answering it. (chuckles)
$500,000
for 33% of the business.
That means
you're valuing this concept
at a million and a half dollars.
Yes.
You don't make any money yet.
All right, why's it worth
a million and a half dollars?
We have an incredible brand.
We have an incredible product.
People are crazy
about our product.
You guys,
I am not just saying that.
I get testimonials from people
that receive our bikes
that are literally so excited
they're almost crying.
Our bikes in any bike Shop
would blow away
anybody in this market.
We're just trying to do it
a different way
because it's
a made-to-Order bike.
I've funded the whole business
with my own cash.
I haven't--
and--And how much
has that been?
$185,000.
$185,000?
Out of my retirement account,
too.
So sometimes
what's happening is, right now,
we're actually stalling
our growth by--We're saying,
hey, we're no longer
taking orders right now.
And we will cut people off
for a little bit of time.
And people wanna
buy the bikes,
but we can't build them
fast enough.
Yeah, that's a pretty sexy
sales approach, though,
to say, "We're running behind."
Customers love it.
They tend to stay with you.
Yeah, it's True.
I have two words for you.
Great design.
Thank you.
Incredible. But...
I appreciate that
coming from you.
Even though
It's a great design,
it's just a space
I don't want to be in.
I'm out.
No problem.
Let me give you a little
endorsement as to your price,
because I am your sweet spot.
I buy, on average,
four bikes a year.
It sounds absurd.
Dang.
And I buy them
without the speed.
I just--These simple bikes.
And I pay, every single year,
$550 per bike
to get a piece of crap
that doesn't last
at a beach resort I live in,
'cause it rots.
Exactly.
All right? They don't
look sexy. They don't look fun.
This is like a cute little
corvette, but it's a bike.
So how much
are you offering him, Barbara?
I'm not. I'm just...
I'm just telling you this
price point is a great deal...
that was--That was worth...
for this kind of bike.
That advice was worth
what you paid for it.
This product is
a total, total Winner.
I am 100% certain.
I'm very much stuck on the value
you've put on your business.
It's not profitable.
Look, you've taken a commodity,
a bicycle,
and made it
a fashion statement.
Correct.
That's cool.
I even like the dog.
But I am not gonna give you
$500,000
for a third of this company.
You're just--I-I don't know
if the company's worth
half a million dollars yet.
I mean, it's--It's--
It's embryonic at this point.
You've gotta sell a ton of bikes
to prove it out.
20 bikes a day, we're doing
$4.3 million a year.
This is a untapped market.
There's people
that see our bikes
that don't even know
this type of bike exists.
You're not a bad salesman.
I gotta tell ya.
Thank you.
I mean, I'm impressed.
But look, I'm out.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
but Fleetwood still has
three more chances
to make a deal.
Fleetwood, I think
you're on to something.
I-I buy into the concept.
I love the bikes.
But I think you're trying
to grow too fast, too quickly.
I think you gotta prove
more of the concept,
'cause there are
other competitors.
You gotta catch
your market share.
There's no other competitor
in what we do.
There's cruiser bicycles
that all look the same
that are
in your local bike shop...
right.
That cost almost as much
as these.
Fleetwood, I can't get there
on the $500,000.
I'm out.
All right.
Where is your brand
on that bike?
I'm not seeing it
as I look at it.
These are all handmade,
hand-Painted
limited edition badges.
But that goes on the very front
as I'm seeing that.
Correct, which is
how bikes do it. Okay?
Mm-hmm.
We also do custom seat covers,
custom designs, branding.
Anything, chains or, like--
This is a show-Off bike.
It really is.
I know you guys are saying
It's expensive,
but think about it.
For $650, you are--
Yeah, I'm not saying it.
No, those are these guys.
I'm not thinking
it's expensive either.
No. Thank you.
Appreciate that.
Barbara, Barbara,
I agree with you in that
for a show-Off,
this is it.
There is nothing else
like that.
For $650, you're getting
transportation, exercise,
eco-Friendly,
and head-Turning.
People can't--
Stop.
You've sold me.
I would really like
to make an offer on this deal.
I could smell the money
flowing from trees.
You wanna partner on this
with me?
Yeah, I do, actually.
But I-I don't think 30%
is enough.
I would agree.
That's the difference.
Not even for
This incredible product here?
(mark) That's not the point.
(laughs)
It's gonna take
a lot of money, honey.
(Robert) Wow.
Look, the point, it's--It's--
It's the amount of money,
but it's also--Success requires
effort, as you know.
For us to really contribute,
it has to be more than capital.
And so I think
that's the difference.
And so I would be willing--
If Barbara wants
to split it with me--
$500,000
for 45% of the company.
You know, mark, you plucked
that 45% right out of my head.
There you go.
So if Barbara's in agreement--
So we've gotta be right.
Two people think this way.
Barbara can definitely
hook us up in New York,
which is critical and--
Forget about New York.
I could hook you up everywhere.
Yeah. So the offer is,
Barbara and I jointly together,
$500,000 for 45% of the company.
Okay, I got a--
I got a question for you.
Sure.
What about 40%?
Because here's the deal...
really, honestly, I feel like
we're about to just explode.
We are about to take off.
And I feel like I'm really
giving up a huge amount of money
for basically
2 1/2 years of...
I haven't made a penny.
I've put a lot into this.
I've created the brand.
I-I know we've got...
not 2 1/2 years.
Yes, it is 2 1/2 years.
It's way more than that
because you come as a talent
as well.
Right.
Okay. Props. I agree.
So your blood, sweat,
and tears.
Okay, what if we split
the difference?
42%?
Barbara?
42%'s okay with me.
I'll do--You do 42%...
we got a deal?
I think that we got a deal,
and I think you guys got
an incredible deal.
That's the only kind
of deals we do. (laughs)
And a fun deal as well.
Cool.
Ah!
And my first Order is gonna be
for a mavs version.
You got it.
You gotta put me ahead
of the line. I'm ordering one.
You got it. All right. Okay.
Thanks, man.
Thanks, guys! Appreciate it.
Giving up 42%,
I feel like I gave away
a little bit too much,
but I do think mark and Barbara
were the right choice for us.
So overall, I'm really happy
and I am excited.